make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and for
today's beyond omega-level video we're
gonna tackle a character from the DC
Universe since we've been fairly Marvel
heavy in this series recently and we're
gonna talk about a character that's been
mentioned a few times in the comment
section Captain Atom now as we get into
the origin of Captain Atom we'll see
that although he is a DC character now
he actually didn't start out that way
and we'll see that there have been
multiple incarnations of his character
so the first version of Captain Atom was
created by Joe Gill and Steve Ditko and
made his appearance in space adventures
number three in 1960 published by
Charlton comics now he was a scientist
named Allen Adham who joined the US Air
Force and attained the rank of captain
get it Captain Atom but anyway he's
working on a rocket at Cape Canaveral
and has accidentally launched into space
and as it turns out the rocket was also
carrying an atomic bomb that detonated
vaporizing atom who would rima t
realized back at the launch site of
course and had powers such as flight
energy blast shields phasing and
invulnerability and so he takes on the
less than creative moniker of Captain
atom and begins working as a superhero
for the military and so this version of
Captain atom would go on to get his own
solo series from 1965 to 1975 now in the
late 70s and early 1980s Charlton comics
began to experience some financial
troubles and the rights to many of
Charlton's characters including Captain
Atom were acquired by DC Comics in 1983
and so the original plan for these
characters were for them to be used in a
story written by Alan Moore however that
plan would be scrapped and Moore would
use original characters based on the
Charlton heroes instead and as a result
we got one of the most well regarded
comics of all time The Watchmen with the
character of dr. Manhattan being heavily
based on Captain Atom
now the Charlton characters would
eventually be introduced into the DC
Universe during crisis on Infinite
Earths in 1985 where they were revealed
to inhabit earth 4 which would merge
with the existing DC Universe in the new
unified continuity now the original
Captain Atom made his final appearance
in 1986 and would quickly be replaced
with a new version in 1987's Captain
Atom number 1 by Cary Bates and Pat
Broderick now this new version of
Captain Atom was Nathaniel Adam also a
captain in the Air Force and this time a
veteran of the Vietnam War he was framed
for crime and sentenced to death but was
allowed to avoid his sentence by
agreeing to participate in a secret
government experiment co named project
captain Adam in exchange for his
presidential pardon Nathan agrees to
take part in the testing
alien ships durability by going into the
craft and remaining there while an
atomic bomb underneath it was detonated
not surprisingly he's totally
disintegrated but would reappear 18
years later with the medal of the alien
craft now bonded to his body and allowed
him to access the quantum field which
granted him immense powers it also
turned out that because he was presumed
dead his pardon never went through so
he's forced into working for the
government as a superhero Captain Atom
now as far as Kevin Adams powers go as a
result to the experiment his skin is
bonded with the alien metal known as del
estal which is actually part of an alien
being called silver shield which allows
him to tap into the quantum field a
seemingly limitless source of energy
captain Adams ability to absorb and
control this energy is limited only by
his own will and imagination which I
feel like isn't saying a lot lately in
these beyond omega-level videos but he
routinely uses his energy to fly and
give himself superhuman strength not
invulnerability and super speed among
other things in terms of strength he's
been shown to be able to break free from
the grasp of Superman and to break a
hard light construct created by Hal
Jordan his speed is such that he's been
able to catch the black racer who's one
of the fastest characters in the DC
Multiverse and claims that he can reach
the speed of light furthermore captain
Adams durability allows him to endure
insane amounts of damage without any ill
effects mostly due to his ability to
absorb an insane amount of energy and
has been able to absorb all the energy
generated by the detonation of a nuclear
warhead with no real setbacks I guess
the best way to put it
captain Adam is also able to survive
without air water and food and has been
able to survive the vacuum of a black
hole without being harmed although
impressive superhuman strength speed and
durability are only the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to captain Adams
powers as his ability to manipulate
energy allows him to do basically
whatever he wants of course he can use
the ability offensively and dish out a
huge amount of damage creating
concussive energy blasts who are capable
of destroying everything within a pretty
large radius even more impressively his
energy manipulation seems to grant him
reality-warping powers as well in one
instance he destroyed an entire universe
simply because his dog died and then
recreated the universe that his dog was
alive and in fact he did this again
three times casually tearing down all of
reality and building it back up to suit
his own will in addition to reality
manipulation captain Adam is also
capable of matter manipulation having
vapor
individuals from existence with a single
touch and on another occasion he turned
arrows that were being fired at him into
harmless butterflies
even though arrows would surely not have
had any effects on him even if they had
hit him and so in captain Adam we have a
character who's probably as strong as
Superman seemingly indestructible and
able to manipulate energy matter in
reality that in and of itself is enough
to put captain Adam well beyond
omega-level but there are actually a
couple other versions of the character
that I want to touch on before we in the
video because they're even more powerful
than the main version so when captain
Adam is attacked by a monitor his skin
is damaged and he has to put on armor
from the villain monarch to keep his
energy contained however due to the
trauma of the attack captain Adam goes
insane so his potential for manipulating
quantum energy is no longer tempered by
any moral code and so he just lets loose
with reckless abandon while in this
state
captain Adam destroys the city of
Bludhaven and states that he's capable
of destroying entire worlds he
transported several versions of various
heroes from different dimensions to an
arena and killed most of them he was
also able to defeat three versions of
Superman classic Superman red Sun and
Christopher Kent the biological son of
Zod from Superman the last son as well
as 51 other versions of himself from
other Earth's monarch as he's now called
claims he possesses nearly as much
energy as the Big Bang monarch then
battles superman primed to a stalemate
and when his suit is punched the energy
released kills everyone in the universe
of earth 51 with the exception of the
monitor so yeah the version of Monarch
of Captain Atom is even more
ridiculously powerful than the normal
version and the same can be said for the
new 52 version of his character as well
who got a big power upgrade when DC
rebooted his continuity he also received
a new origin as this time kathandol atom
volunteers for an experiment being
conducted on the quantum field and is
once again accidentally vaporized and
then reappears as a being of pure energy
the atoms that comprise this version of
Captain Atom are constantly dividing and
reforming which makes him immensely
powerful but also molecularly unstable
this version of Captain Atom is also
insanely powerful and is able to
manipulate matter at a molecular level
he's able to transform objects such as
turning hot magma into snow or turning a
fighter plane into feathers he's able to
heal others in one instance repairing a
woman's hand that's been severely
damaged by cancer and radiation
and on another example removing a
child's brain tumor he was able to
manipulate reality by pulling thoughts
from the mind of those around him and
creating matter out of nothing so he was
an extremely powerful reality warper in
this form this form of Captain Atom
while powerful was short-lived as the
version that we've seen since the launch
of DC's latest line wide revamp DC
rebirth is far more similar to the
post-crisis version than the new 52 but
yeah
Captain Atom is way beyond Omega level
in this form right in any of these forms
it's ridiculous or at least any of his
forms since he was brought into the DC
universe this makes a lot of sense when
we consider that he was the blueprint
for dr. Manhattan and the dr. Manhattan
was revealed to be sort of a god of the
DC Universe in Doomsday Clock or at
least a god-like entity at the very
least and it is full potential
we know that Captain Atom is capable of
wiping out entire universes due to the
seemingly infinite amount of energy at
his disposal through his connection to
the quantum field but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explained to make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]